mr president ladies and gentlemen
members of the court
appointed member of the european commission by
the european council following the vote of
approval by the european parliament i
solemnly undertake to respect in the
exercise of all my duties
the treaties and the charter of
fundamental rights of the european union
he  it will be my responsibilities with
complete independence in the general
union is not to request nor accept instructions in the
exercise of my attributions from
any government institution
body body is not to practice any
act incompatible with the nature of
my
functions which the exercise of my attributions has
taken good note of  obligation foreseen in the
treaty on the functioning of the
european union by virtue of which each
member state must respect this principle and
not seek to influence the members of the
commission in the exercise of their
attributions
I also undertake to respect it
during the exercise of my functions and
after the  cessation of months  but the duties
arising from my office namely the
duties of a city and description with
regard to acceptance after the end
of my term of office certain duties
points certain benefits
mercy